[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle année et nouvelle année
évidemment pour audition publique
l'émission du lundi soir en direct
lcp assemblée nationale public sénat et
le figaro lie très bonne année à vous
tous donc et puis soyez de plus en plus
nombreux à nous suivre bien entendu nous
sommes repartis pour une heure de direct
comme je vous le disais est notre invité
pour commencer cette année aujourd'hui
et marc fesneau bonsoir vous êtes
ministre des relations avec le parlement
membre du modem et vous allez en voir
tout à l'heure sur le plateau des
parlementaires qui vont vous interrogez
à la suite de mes consoeurs des chaînes
parlementaires et puis yves thréard du
figaro viendra aussi vous poser ces
questions à son tour plus évidemment les
questions des téléspectateurs qu'on peut
nous faire parvenir via le figaro life
et que je relaierai au fur et à mesure
mais tout de suite on va commencer avec
brigitte boucher de lcp assemblée
nationale et âme traduit de public sénat
bonjour brigitte et à metz que vous êtes
prête pour 2020 malheureusement
absolument je suis là brigitte oui on
commence avec vos bonjour marc fesneau
vous avez retiré temporairement l'âge
pivot de la réforme des retraites
est-ce que cela n'a pas ouvert la porte
à un retrait total de cette réforme a
pas du tout c'était j'étais dans le
dialogue qui avait eu avec les
organisations syndicales la volonté que
nous avons eue de faire un pas vers l
pascal un compromis c'est de faire des
pas les uns vers les autres
mais par ailleurs que cette réforme est
la question de son financement soit
posée dans le temps législatif qui
serait le doute qui nous amène jusqu'à
la fin de session
cet été et donc c'est un moyen pour
montrer que nous sommes ouverts au
dialogue de parts et d'autres d'ailleurs
et en même temps évidemment la réforme
elle est au coeur de nos préoccupations
et ses d'examen de la réforme débutera
dans quelques semaines à l'assemblée
nationale c'est comment on fait en sorte
dans ce pays de 2,2 dialoguer de trouver
des voies de compromis qui ne sont pas
des compromissions chacun étaient sur
une position nous avons décidé de
converger pour pouvoir discuter de la
question du financement notamment du
coût de financement à court terme pour
l'instant et bien la réforme allait dans
les mains des partenaires sociaux s'il
n'y a pas d'accord fin avril est ce que
vous nous garantissez que l'âge pivot ne
reviendra pas c'est la crainte de ceux
qui sont opposés à cette raison qu'on
peut pas à la fois ouvrir depuis samedi
les voies d'un compromis et d'un
dialogue et faire confiance au fond et
se faire confiance et commencer par se
mettre dans la posture ou dans la
situation qu'ils n'aboutiraient un échec
moi j'ai entendu les partenaires sociaux
les responsables patronaux les
responsables des organisations
syndicales de salariés dire on a les
voies et moyens on a des solutions on a
des choses qu'on peut mettre sur la
table on a un cocktail de mesures qui
peuvent permettre de financer et donc
moi je fais confiance aux partenaires
sociaux pour trouver une solution
nous sommes venus pour dire lâche qui
vous ne revinrent ailleurs le premier
ministre hier à dix et pour finir de
répondre à la question effectivement il
a dit je tiendrai compte de ce qui a été
dit avec les partenaires sociaux mais
notre exigence à nous c'est pas on n'a
pas un totem autour de l'âge pivot on
n'en fait pas un point de fixation pour
ne pas dire de fixette
notre obsession c'est de faire en sorte
que le système de retraites pour être
crédibles soient financés et donc c'est
la mesure qui a été mis sur la table
c'est ce qu'avait dit le point ministre
ssq a redit pour les ministres
d'ailleurs hier en disant il nous semble
que c'est la meilleure mesure mais si
les partenaires se sont qu'elle trouve
autre chose oui oui si on est dans cette
vous avez lu ce que disait le premier
ministre vous avez écouté ce que dit
fort justement c'était moi qui me l'a
dit je peu après l'airé du dire que je
prendrai mes responsabilités ça veut
dire quoi je prendrai mes
responsabilités de financement par
ailleurs d'auxi du mois jeudi pour leur
mère non mais par ailleurs il peut y
avoir une discussion qui n'aboutissent
pas à un accord complet entre les
partenaires sociaux mais qu'ils soient
des solutions complémentaires de celles
que nous avions offert oui ce que veut
dire et donc c'est dans le mix des
propositions qu'on verra on peut pas
lancer ce débat là et dire qu'on va
qu'on est prêts à dialoguer et commencé
par dire de toute façon on ira l'âge
pivot l'âge pivot c'est depuis le début
le premier ministre a dit que c'était
ouvert à la discussion
et donc c'est ouvert à la discussion à
dire qu'il est retiré mais le premier
ministre a dit très clairement les
choses dans son écrit donc ne demandez
pas ce qui n'est pas écrit ce qui est
écrit c'est retirons de rasoir ne lâche
pas écrit non mais nous retirons
provisoirement la fio nous faisons
confiance aux partenaires sociaux jeudi
de revenir cette année ce n'est pas la
question puisque si on si on avait comme
oblig comme objet de définitivement
mettre l'âge pivot on devrait partir et
lâche plus haut donc si on l'a retiré
provisoirement puisque c'est comme ça
que ça a été formulée c'est bien avec la
volonté qu'on trouve d'autres solutions
il ya le projet vote sur la réforme des
retraites qui va venir en discussion au
parlement avant la fin des conclusions
en fait de la conférence de financement
est-ce que vous ne trouvez pas que le
travail parlementaire et quelque peu
bafouée non je ne crois pas ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas la première fois que de
cette façon de procéder de cette façon
je rappelle avoir un problème juste non
je crois pas parce qu'on peut pas à la
fois dire ya pas de démocratie sociale
ont fait pas débattre les partenaires
sociaux que là on lance un processus
il ya un moment il faut qu'on avance
quand même sur le sujet
l'essentiel de la réforme qui porte sur
le système par points le principe
d'universalité la fin des régimes
spéciaux des mécanismes de transition
tout ça c'est c'est la réforme le coeur
de la réforme et après nous avons un
sujet que nous avons mis sur la table
qui est le sujet du financement parce
que ça crédibilise l'ensemble mais enfin
ça n'est pas le seul sujet de la réforme
que vous en disiez que les
parlementaires vont être obligés de
voter quelque chose qui est encore en
cours de négociation
les parlementaires se saisiront aussi du
travail de négociation oui en quoi c'est
un problème on
les votes si jamais on devait travailler
les parlementaires avant on dirait il
travaille sans les partenaires sociaux
que ça soit concomitants ne me gêne pas
et je répète je pense à la réforme de la
sncf du l'ouverture à la concurrence de
la sncf comment s'est passé le débat un
certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
inscrits dans la loi au fur et à mesure
des négociations et je pense qu'on a
abouti à quelque chose qui était un
compromis acceptable par tous les
parlementaires ont se sont plutôt réjoui
de voir inscrit dans le dur ce qui était
l'objet d'une négociation à vous non
elle a été en cours non elle a été en
cours d'examen du texte
je viendrai bien sûr cela dérange en
tout cas c'est le président du sénat
gérard larcher qui veut reporter
l'examen du projet de loi
il veut avoir une étude d'impact il va
attendre les conclusions de la
conférence de financement vous ne le
comprenais pas je ne partage pas son
sentiment pour les raisons que je viens
d'évoquer le sénat procédera à l'examen
de ce texte fin avril où seront
d'ailleurs dans le le moment où où cette
conférence rendra ses conclusions il ya
une navette parlementaire classique il
ya tout le temps et toute la capacité à
ce que les parlementaires se saisissent
du texte et se saisissent aussi des
attendus s'expliquent danger mais ce que
eux gérard larcher la semaine dernière
lorsqu'il a fait cette proposition était
également très offensif envers le
gouvernement et est il dans son rôle de
président du sénat pour vous ou
d'opposants politiques et pas mais il
est à la fois président du sénat est
manifestement il est plutôt en situation
de position politique moi j'ai
d'excellents rapports avec le président
politique mais le président larcher ne
fait pas partie de la majorité on va pas
lui faire grief de ne fait pas faire
partie de la majorité mais en même temps
j'ai comment il est président du sénat
oui on est président du sénat mais il a
une étiquette politique que le président
larcher et c'est bien légitime comme
vous ne voyez pas daigné communistes des
relations avec le parlement comme
responsable public tout court le fait au
président larcher de penser et de penser
y compris différemment du gouvernement
dans un jeu politique mais probablement
qu'il ya quelque chose du jeu politique
qu'il faut accepter parce qu'après tout
c'est le débat moi je pense qu'on peut
trouver avec le sénat la vérité c'est
qu'il ya ce qu'on dit puel et les actes
et le président du sénat dans un certain
nombre et le sénat a d'ailleurs pas que
le président du sénat dans un certain
nombre de textes de loi on procède à des
commissions mixtes paritaires qui sont
conclusive
ils attendent de voir la plupart donc on
va attendre de voir est plutôt optimiste
oui
je comprends toutes les postures
politiques parce que ça peut être des
nécessités des sites externes
je peux même accepté qu'on ne soit pas
d'accord avec le président du sénat
s'était pas démocratique on va pas
reprocher au président du sénat de ne
pas être d'accord à tous d'accord mais
on peut pas nous reprocher de ne pas
être d'accord
oui mais moi je pense que le débat
démocratique qui dessin dès lors qu'il
est de bonne foi donc voilà dès lors
qu'il est de bonne foi après il ya des
rumeurs de 49,3 qui qui courent sur
cette réforme des retraites
peut-être d'un dîner à l'elysée mardi
dernier est ce que voulait tuer dans
l'oeuf tout de suite ou est ce que vous
dites c'est envisageable peut-être pour
faire taire des oppositions parce qu'on
sait qu'il va y avoir des moments durs
quand même dans l'hémicycle sur ce texte
je ne crains pas le débat sur ce texte
dont je pense et de cette réforme dont
je pense qu'elle est juste qu'elle est
profondément redistributive donc il y
aura pas de 49 3 mais non parce que le
49-3 l'objet du 49-3 plus dans quel
motif
vous êtes sur le 49-3 c'est quand on
n'est pas sûr de votre majorité et je
peux vous dire que moi je sais que la
majorité
lrm modem est très aligné d'ailleurs au
delà de ça est très alignés sur les
objectifs de la réforme et son mécanisme
de solidarité son universalité
le deuxième motif c'est parfois quand il
ya une obstruction ont fait 300 mille
quatre cent mille âmes non je ne sens
pas que l'opposition soit dans 7 dont il
ya aucun motif à encore non mais aucun
motif
je fais confiance à l'opposition pour
avoir un débat qui nourrit un temps
parlementaire qui est prévu que correct
très correct et donc qui permettra à
chacun de s'exprimer d'avoir des
positions et des oppositions enfin là
aussi c'est simple et c'est ça qu'il ya
des oppositions penser qu'elles sont
durs justement cette opposition a
manifestement tout cas ce que j'entends
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elles sont plutôt
durs est rude pour un certain nombre
d'entre elles vous avez y aura peut-être
une bataille d'amendements mieux encore
à papier on n'est pas dans les tuyaux du
gouvernement de procéder aux 49 points
faut qu'on ait un débat débat public ça
permettra aux uns et aux autres aussi de
se positionner ceux qui disent que c'est
pas assez juste
et au fond il ya des tas de mécanismes
de redistribution et de justice sociale
ça mettra chacun au pied de ses
responsabilités il ya ceux qui disent
depuis des années il faut faire
converger les résidus spéciaux vers un
régime universel c'est la droite et à
ceux qui disent la réforme n'est pas
juste pas on les mettra au pied du oui
et donc on les mettra devant leurs
responsabilités au moment du vote parce
qu'il ya quand même un certain nombre de
mécanismes il reviendra peut-être pas ce
soir mais un certain nombre de
mécanismes qui sont justement en parlant
de temps parlementaire un vote avant
l'été et il vraiment
réaliste l'assemblée nationale doit
cesser les travaux parlementaires début
juillet il ya les élections municipales
au milieu ça paraît compliqué je suis
mise des relations avec le parlement les
calendrier parlementaire il est prévu
pour que dans le mécanisme habituel d'un
texte de loi il soit il soit votée ça
donne l'été quasiment mutuelle oui bah
oui qu'est ce qui est inhabituel dans ce
que l'on me dit tiens il ya six mois de
temps et de débat parlementaire ça me
parait il n'y a pas une loi qui sera
mise un peu retardé
non mais apprendre à regarder calendrier
le public à raison qu'ils remettront un
regard après on va là des priorités de
calendrier la priorité on verra à ce
moment là il ya un séminaire
gouvernemental le 15
mercredi prochain qui permettra de re
calibrer le calendrier avec la volonté
que nous avons pour y avoir des lois
qu'ils soient forcément si vous nous
imposez vous intégrez un texte il peut y
avoir un petit mouvement de calendrier
qui n'est pas un mouvement de calendrier
aux calendes grecques et un mouvement de
calendrier qui permet d'obtenir six mois
c'est presque déjà une calendes grecques
ah bon d'accord
est ce que vous prévoyez de rencontrer
les différents présidents de groupe pour
organiser les travaux pour définir la
méthode de travail m'appartient pas
forcément de le faire sans doute les
ministres en charge de ces questions et
2 du texte sur les retraites et puis
l'assemblée nationale et même qui
organisera les travaux pour qui ce passe
dans des conditions de débat on a besoin
d'un débat sur cette question des
retraites d'un débat il ya un début un
débat public ni un débat aussi à
l'assemblée nationale est un débat au
sénat bien pourtant vous avez choisi la
procédure accélérée
oui enfin pardonnez-moi la procédure
d'irak dite accélérée c'est la procédure
qui est utilisé dans les trois-quarts 80
ou 90% des textes ses adversaires de ce
soir là et c'est plutôt moi quand j'ai
été même en direct quand j'étais
rapporteur du texte de révision
constitutionnelle on s'est beaucoup
interrogé là-dessus le texte n'a pas
abouti ou pas encore abouti mais cette
procédure c'est la procédure de
finalement de normes
la plupart des gouvernements utilisent
cette procédure il ya quelques textes
sur lequel on ne le fait pas donc tous
les textes et a abouti dans ce
quinquennat dans ce début de quinquennat
ont été nos sources et de procédure
accélérée quand vous avez quinze jours
ou trois semaines de débats sané ça
permet quand même le débat quelle est la
différence
juste pour dire c'est qu'on donne la
chance à la commission mixte paritaire
de pouvoir se réunir pour conclure un
accord et quand il ya un accord entre
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
moi je vais vous dire je trouve que
c'est une bonne nouvelle ça veut dire
que des gens qui ne pensent pas la même
chose qui sont dans l'opposition au
gouvernement et qui sont dans la
majorité trouvent un terrain de
compromis mais moi je trouve que là
aussi quand on arrive à faire
les compromis c'est plutôt plus dur au
niveau parlementaire verra table
justement les échanges s'annoncent dures
sur ce texte vous l'avez reconnue vous
allez en plus à voir et bien un novice
du gouvernement au banc laurent pied
trajet ce qui est ce que ça va rendre le
travail du gouvernement plus difficile
est ce que ça va demander à ce que soit
ils leurs philippe qui montent au
créneau crois pas du tout enfin c'est
pas c'est peut-être un touriste comme
membres du gouvernement ce n'est pas un
novice comme parlementaire il a étrillé
quand même sur le nombre lors du débat
sur les retraites dans l'échangé par la
semaine dernière dans quel état d'esprit
où j'ai pas du tout la même lecture que
vous j'ai eu le compte-rendu juste tous
les jours les comptes rendus des débats
g
j'ai regardé un peu ce qui s'était passé
évidemment c'est normal elles m'ont dit
que c'était un carnage jouez vous voit
vous citer beaucoup les sénateurs g en
tout cas c'est pas les états majors non
mais c'est pas les échos que j'en ai eu
moi je crois que laurent pietrasinski
connaît très bien ces sujets là il y
aura un débat après sur le fond non pas
sur un texte qu'on ne connaît pas sur un
texte qu'on connaîtra avec des
amendements des uns et des autres et
donc ça sera intéressant à ce moment-là
de regarder les uns et les autres
comment ils se positionnent et ils ont
rempli un travesti quelqu'un qui connaît
très bien ces sujets là qui par ailleurs
une pratique parlementaire il était par
ailleurs parlementaire et donc qu'il
connaît bien aussi la manière de
conduire les débats
il connaît ses collègues mais oui il
n'ya pas de beaucoup de marge de
manoeuvre sur ce texte de la réforme des
retraites et notamment sur le
financement puisque le premier ministre
a dit qu'il aurait pas de hausses de
cotisations pas de baisse des pensions
est ce que vous n'êtes pas en train de
refaire aux syndicats le coût de
l'assurance chômage ou finalement une
finale où le gouvernement avait repris
la main et durci les critères
je ne crois pas et d'ailleurs si les
syndicats dits réformistes se sont
engagés très vite après la déclaration
du courrier du premier ministre pour
dire on y va sur sur l'idée d'une
conférence du financement c'est qu'ils
nous font confiance et que nous leur
faisons confiance donc il faut se faire
confiance dans la vie qu'est ce qui
s'est passé sur la réforme de
l'assurance chômage que nous avions
donné du temps nous avions d'ailleurs
donné du temps supplémentaire
simplement les partenaires sociaux
organisations patronales les
organisations de salariés n'étaient pas
d'accord sur la façon de financer un
moment là et objet de prendre nos
responsabilités mais pour un
gouvernement s'étant les critères
d'entrée au delà de tout ça les français
ils voient bien que c'est plus dur
maintenant danny messer
si la volonté pour nous avec une
politique très active en terme d'emploi
en termes de formation professionnelle
manié par muriel pénicaud en particulier
de faire de faciliter le fait que les
gens puissent retrouver facilement un
emploi mais qu'en même temps les
conditions d'accès à l'allocation
chômage soit de nature différente pour
payer une prime à ceux qui essayent de
se réintégrer dans le travail on va
revenir aux retraites via les sénateurs
oui ils font vraiment entendre leurs
différences les retraites n'avait pas
échappé des vous allez voir les
retraites aussi des sénateurs qui
défendent le maintien de leur caisse
autonome à ce que vous ministre des
relations avec le parlement vous les
comprenez j'ai pas tout à fait entendu
ça j'ai entendu le président larcher et
les sénateurs dire que évidemment il
serait dans le régime de tout le monde
sait ça ils vont adopter la retraite à
points
mais voilà donc les sénateurs seront
dans le régime général oui mais ils
veulent dire dès lors qu'elles sont ou
non mais il ya une autre chose après il
ya les retraites complémentaires
je me suis jamais ça excusez moi de vous
dire que dans le régime universel il ya
des retraites complémentaires puisque
vous surcotiser donc c'est ils seront je
crois j'ai cru entendre du président de
marché je trouve ça très sain et très
normal au fond qu'il serait dans le
régime universel qui ne dérogerai pas à
la règle de la du système à points après
par ailleurs ils ont un système de
retraites complémentaires comme d'état
de français qui nous écouteront des
systèmes n'ont ils pas les députés les
aussi les députés n'ont pas fait le
choix d'une retraite complète voilà et
on savait le bug des deux poids deux
mesures mais c'est le choix souverain
des assemblées européenne a choisi de
surcotiser quand vous avez une retraite
complémentaire vous avez certes mais
laissons donc les députés n'ont pas fait
ce choix là ils ont toujours la latitude
d'ailleurs de faire un chemin vers son
camp notamment un système universel et
son système le régime général de base ou
un spécificité vu lewis elle et des
avocats qui manifestent encore
aujourd'hui est ce que vous allez faire
une exception aussi ils ont des réserves
importantes
une exception comme pour les danseurs
comme pour les pilotes comme pour les
policiers par exemple pendant que vous
dire qu'il ya pas d'exception le régime
il sera universel par points
deux éléments de réponses ou trois
éléments de réponses d'abord vous dites
ils ont des réserves
premier ministre s'est engagé à l'idée
qu'on ne toucherait pas aux réserves
pour financer le système que les
réserves pourrait servir soit faire des
affaires complémentaires soient
organisées les mécanismes de transition
alors si bête ndiaye ce matin a dit bon
on pourrait quand même vérifier si on
pourrait pas prendre dans les réserves
de temps en temps et fléchés sur
certaines de mes remèdes
ça nous permet de détendre c'est dans
les mécanismes de transition c'est
exactement ce que je sais en train
d'être d'accord c'est un jeu 2 quel est
le débat que nous avons avec les avocats
c'est sans doute le débat mais nous
sommes les uns les autres jeunes qui a
eu avec les agriculteurs en 45 quand le
système a été mis en place les
agriculteurs en 45 ont refusé d'intégrer
le régime général parce qu'ils avaient
une démographie qui perd favorable et
que donc ayant beaucoup d'actifs et peu
de cotisants il estimait que le régime
avait été plus profitable c'est ce que
disent les avocats et on peut l'entendre
sauf que dans la tendance générale
évidemment la démographie se stabilisera
puis ceux des se dégradera pour les
avocats et nous on veut créer un système
universel qui soit durable et donc pour
les avocats on est dans la merde si le
taux de cotisation et va passer trois
ans d'aventurés mais par pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont une démographie favorable de
nos jours 11 par l'épi troisième sujet
c'est pas les pilotes l'épaule c'est
après au delà des organisations d où des
caisses il ya des métiers qui sont plus
pénibles que d'autres mais c'est les
métiers qui sont plus pénibles et donc
par la peur le statut c'est pas le
statut ni l'entreprise qui crée la
différence qui crée la différence c'est
quand vous êtes couvreur et que vous
êtes sur un toit oui votre métier est
sans doute plus pénible
j'ai aucun doute sur le fait qu'il soit
plus pénible quand vous êtes ministre
alors avant d'aller sur autre chose
il ya du mieux dans les transports
aujourd'hui oui un peu moins de
grévistes est ce que pour vous c'est le
début de la sortie du conflit
en tout cas je constate les choses vous
n'aurez pas entendu d'ailleurs de la
part du gouvernement un quelconque
triomphalisme on a envie de convaincre
et de faire en sorte que les compromis
que la capacité dialogue se noue y
compris dans le moment parlementaires y
compris avec ceux qui ne pouvaient ne
pas être d'accord
je constate effectivement que petit à
petit donc c'était plus dans le rêve
pour ça en tout cas je constate le fait
qu'à moins de grévistes est que beaucoup
de parisiens ont témoigné aujourd'hui du
fait que j'ai qui l'ont notamment
aujourd'hui à la ratp il y avait un
certain nombre d'améliorations était une
nouvelle attraction est prévue jeudi est
ce que ce sera le baromètre est ce que
vous vous regarderez s'il ya du monde à
chaque journée d'action est un baromètre
regarder la partie purement celle-là oui
forcément
tournant peut-être ou pas oui enfin moi
mais sans quoi le tournant c'est l'idée
qu'un certain nombre de syndicats qui
était favorable la réforme disons ni
presse mais tout face à lorient c'est
bien le rugby vous ne gouverner pas
uniquement avec la rue je pense qu'on
peut être d'accord avec ce principe
la mobilisation syndicale on en tient
compte on la regarde
mais si vous êtes simplement sur ce
baromètre là et que seul le nombre de
manifestants indique votre opinion
politique sur une réforme je pense que
cette inquiétante tendance à faire pour
arriver au compromis parce que il y
avait 40 genre détail nous avions
volonté de compromis de l'année attendre
car toujours comme est nommé pour faire
un compromis faut être pardonnez moi de
vous le dire deux il faut que chacun
fasse un pas et le premier ministre dès
le 11 décembre avait dit je suis prêt au
compromis notamment sur cette question
du film alors maintenant d'autres
questions au delà des retraites qui
s'adresse à vous marc fesneau ministre
des relations avec le parlement
oui et qu'il y avait une grande
expérience d'élu local les grandes
associations d'élus locaux et les maires
les départements et les régions étaient
réunis ce matin ont fait leurs voeux
elles ont dénoncé également la
suppression des étiquettes dans les
listes pour les villes de moins de 9000
habitants ça concerne bien sûr les
prochaines élections municipales
déjà et bien vos relations avec les élus
locaux n'étaient pas très bonne est ce
que c'est un nouveau coin qui elles ont
foncé
quel est le sujet au fond moi j'étais
maire d'une commune de 700 habitants
tout le monde savait que j'étais au
modem mais je n'aimais pas qu'on dise
laver la commune de marché noir
d'une certaine façon gagné par le modem
parce que dans les 14 autres colistiers
que j'avais il n'était pas au modem avec
fierté dans beaucoup de villes d'autres
qui est prêté à monaco mais moi je
connais plus qu'on croise et des élus
locaux qui n'aimait pas qu'on les
étiquettes
oui mais y'en a qui pleurent ce matin de
médiocre manoeuvre politique elle est la
manoeuvre la médiocre manoeuvre
d'ailleurs sur quoi vous allez base et
là on en parlera peut-être tout à
l'heure la réussite électorale des uns
ou des autres élections municipales sur
les villes de plus de 10 mille habitants
enfin faut dire les choses comme elles
sont quelle quelle est la préfecture ou
pas qui bascule de telcamp à tel autre
et donc je trouve que c'est faire un
mauvais griefs que cette affaire-là la
plupart des villes quand vous parlez
d'ailleurs aux élus la plupart d'entre
eux ne mettent pas même leurs étiquettes
sur les affiches on va regarder combien
d' affiches porteront l'étiquette du
parti qui soutient tel ou tel candidat
et ce sera valable
en ville même dans les très grandes
villes c'était étonnant dans ces moments
là les étiquettes disparaissent et après
quand on gagne tout d'un coup on se
réapproprie d'étiquettes tout le monde
je sais que je suis modem et beaucoup de
gens savent combien telle ville le maire
est plutôt peur des associations non
mais quel est l'intérêt de cette
manipulation
une précision de calendrier maintenant
le premier ministre avait promis avant
l'été qu'il y aurait une réforme avec la
baisse du nombre des députés et la
proportionnelle est ce que ce calendrier
est toujours maintenue on va regarder
dans le débat couzon sur le calendrier
parlementaire mercredi prochain quels
sont les éléments qu'on peut avoir sur
le fond il nous paraît intéressant
d'avancé sur ces questions
institutionnelles
après nous avons de solides amitiés
beaucoup à la proportionnelle la
proportionnelle et se changer pour le
tikida vous croyez mais en tout cas je
porte l'idée que ce serait dommage de
d'accord baisse que vous sourira non
l'idée n'est pas abandonnée face au non
plus ça se passe mais on verra mais moi
je pense que ça serait souhaitable
pourquoi parce que ça pousse aussi c'est
pas tant la proportionnelle pour la
proportionnelle c'est pas seulement la
représentation de la diversité des
opinions encore que ce soit pour nous
très important mais ça permet aussi de
créer des coalitions et de créer du
compresseur et donc sa part est là ce
n'est pas gagné mais après nous avons
des affaires de calendrier il ya des
affaires de redécoupage électoral
non mais je peux pas vous dire que c'est
gagné parce que si j'étais ce soir à
vous dire il ya un texte qui arrive au
mois de mai vous me diriez pas comment
c'est possible alors il n'y a qu'à
calendrier qui est assez nourris et
fournit une question précise de
calendrier l'assemblée nationale va
s'engager dans des travaux importants
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il y aura pas
de session extraordinaire et ça veut
dire qu'on s'arrête quand exactement sa
célérité la défense du président de
l'assemblée nationale et que ça s'arrête
là première au début de la première
semaine de juillet je vais à la fin et
début juillet et que donc y aura une
interruption qui dépendra un peu des
deux la nette avancée des travaux très
importants puisque c'est l'ensemble de
la verrière qui doit être fait
c'est une mesure je crois assez
important que c'est un problème
d'urgence et de sécurité et donc on
verra avec le président ferrand les
conditions mais ça n'empêchera pas les
commissions se réunir et de préparer
aussi c'est pas l'interruption des
travaux parlementaires c'est
l'interruption des travaux en hémicycle
donc la réforme des retraites sera votée
c'est sûr à l'organisation du calendrier
parlementaire prévoit que dans cette
contrainte là nous puissions volet noter
la réforme des retraites avant donc ce
10 juillet ouvert avant le moment de
l'interruption qui est plutôt plutôt
rire le 404 5 juillet
oui la réforme des questions au
gouvernement suscite beaucoup de
critiques à l'assemblée deux heures
questions réponses
beaucoup de critiques à l'assemblée et
notamment chez les parlementaires
il devait y avoir une évaluation au mois
de décembre à peu près qu'en est il
et puis vous est-ce que vous
personnellement vous souhaiter qu'il y
ait une évolution
ce n'est pas à moi de m'exprimer là
dessus parce qu'il faut aussi respecter
l'autonomie et la responsabilité du
parlement de l'assemblée nationale comme
du sel alors est-ce que vous allez
enlever votre contrat tendait le
président de l'assemblée nationale l'a
redit récemment conférence de présidents
l'idée que comment dirais-je
il y avait nécessité d'évaluer il
l'avait dit dès le démarrage du vote du
règlement disons qu'il fallait réévaluer
regarder en cours de route on verra ce
que disent les parlementaires ce jour
pas évalué jean fin excusez moi ça a
démarré le 1er octobre et enfin les
routes peut-être que c'est que les
retours 10 telle ou telle chose et qu'on
dise après comment fait évoluer les
choses c'est un autre sujet donc le
président ferrand s'est engagé sur
l'idée que ray une évaluation y aura
donc une évaluation pour regarder qu'est
ce qui fonctionne
qu'est-ce qui peut pardonnez moi mais
c'est pas moi qu'il faut poser les
fusions des prérogatives pardon nous
nous sommes à la disposition du
parlement il ya des questions au
gouvernement les ministres doivent être
au banc et répondre aux questions et
vous en taule mr2 des relations avec le
perdant ça vous va cesser ans qu'il ya
eu deux heures mais c'est pas la
question de la durée et la mise au vert
moi j'ai pas de jeu donc je n'ai pas à
faire de commentaires ça c'est parce que
c'est vous qui répondait aux questions
vous êtes là non mais parce que si je
vous disais ce qui me plaît je
préférerais une heure je préfèrerais le
jeudi je préférerais telle ou telle
chose alors que le droit de réplique me
vendait début de l'année c'est le
veuille ou non les voeux que je fais
alors à ce moment là si vous voulez
jamais axée sur cette question mais vous
savez j'ai plutôt la réputation
ne vous inquiétez pas le voeu que je
fais c'est que nous puissions avoir au
moment de ces questions au gouvernement
qui sont le moment au sénat et à
l'assemblée nationale de visibilité pour
les citoyens que nous ayons à la fois la
capacité d'avoir un vrai débat
démocratique et qu'ils soient pas
caricaturer qui puisse intéresser les
citoyens à la chose publique et donc
c'est avec ça qu'ils faut regarder
l'évaluation c est ce qu on est en en
attention de ce qu'ils perçoivent eux
d'une réalité sociale d'une réalité
économique est ce que les parlementaires
se font bien le relais ce que le
gouvernement répond bien et est ce qui
est assez d'interactivité pour que ça
puisse intéresser les télés souris
sentiment aujourd'hui
ben je sais pas c'est vous qui avez les
audiences j'ai l'impression que les
en sont plutôt corrects mais c'est
plutôt que pour y répondre
j'ai l'impression que les audiences ou à
peu près après on peut regarder
l'exercice qu'est ce qu'on peut
améliorer le droit des choses améliorer
le laisser un peu le temps aussi par
pardonnez moi si vous avez un avis vous
le soumettrait au président fernand mais
les le laisse le temps de la réplique
qui est une pratique au sénat ce sens là
contre réplique c'est à dire la capacité
aux députés de répondre aux ministres
puis maintenant au ministre de répondre
au député qui lui a répondu si je peux
dire oui enfin c'est le 10 mai que sa
folle et c'est aussi le temps de vivre
ça parce que c'est un exercice nouveau à
l'assemblée nationale ils sont allés sur
un plateau de télé merci la semaine
prochaine question de téléspectateurs
que proposez-vous éventuellement pour
remplacer dash pivot mais on peut pas
une question comme ça partout sur le
site du figaro on peut pas avoir dit on
va laisser les parten j'ai bien compris
que c'était sur les retraites si vous
laissez le temps c'est gentil de me
laisser le temps mais ça je pense que
c'est pas trop compliqué parce que au
fond on peut pas dire nous nous pensions
que hp vaud était la solution et nous
pensons que ça peut être la solution
dire aux partenaires sociaux mettez vous
autour de la table travaillons ensemble
pour essayer de trouver une solution
alternative ou un cocktail de solutions
qui permettent de répondre à la question
est que ce soir je viens de vous dire
moi ma solution c'est celle là alors le
même claudius pour toute question quel
amendement pourrait être jugée recevable
par le gouvernement en général sur un
texte d'elle il ya plein de sujets au
travers de sa tête la question de la
pénibilité il ya la question des
mécanismes de transition et la question
de l'emploi des seniors il ya les
questions sans doute du financement
oui à la question du minimum de retraite
il ya la question des pensions de
réversion il ya des tas de sujets qui
vont nourrir le débat et qui permettront
à des parlementaires par excusez moi il
ya beaucoup d'amendements il ya un
certain nombre d'amendements s'ils sont
repris par le 20 sept lavez les régions
récemment sur la loi anti gaspillage
les parlementaires gaspillage et
parlementaires vont justement vous
soumettre leurs questions puisque hbo
gitane à défaut de leur laisser la place
aux parlementaires qui viennent
d'auditions publiques bercy et à la vie
[Musique]
audition publique c'est aussi le lieu où
des parlementaires viennent interpeller
notre invité est ce soir philippe
dallier sénateur et l'air et eric
coquerel députés et les fit ou les deux
seine-saint-denis bonsoir merci d'être
sur ce plateau on commence par eric
coquerel qui voulait me posais une
question lui sur les hauts revenus dans
cette réforme des retraites
oui monsieur fesneau on l'a dit à partir
d'une certaine période les hauts revenus
au dessus de 10000 euros ne seront plus
que deux cotiseront plus qu'à hauteur de
2 8 % lieu de 27 % actuellement
est ce que vous pouvez me dire comment
vous allez faire vous qui prétendez
réformer le système de retraites pour
équilibrer les comptes
pour ce coup-ci équilibrer le trou que
va que va causer ce manque de cotisation
pardonnez moi de vous dire c'est un
point de divergence entre nous c'est pas
le seul l'idée c'est que les revenus au
dessus de 120 mille euros par an pour
faire simple c'est la même chose que ce
que vous dites d'ailleurs cotisent mais
que ça n'ouvre plus de droits alors
qu'auparavant dans la cotisation à 27%
ça ouvrait des droits à la retraite
c'est à dire qu'il voyait croître leur
retraite et donc ce mécanisme là il
permet d'avoir une recette sans avoir en
face une dépense par ailleurs c'est un
temps bien mais alors attendez partir de
2025 comment vous allez faire pour les
gens qui ont pesé mais oui dis pas que
les gens qui ont cotisé des cadres qui
ont donc droit aux retraites qu'ils ont
cotisé alors même que votre système ne
touchera plus les cotisations qui leur
permet de complices assez dans le
mécanisme de transition c'est la même
chose pardonnez-moi douillet moi je vous
dis ça parce que l'âge cargo a estimé
que ça avait coûté 4 milliards d'euros
entre des cadres et pro 2040 soit 72
milliards d'euros à la fin donc
j'aimerais que vous me disiez je suis
cadre j'ai cotisé donc j'ai droit à
recevoir ce pour quoi j'ai cotisé et
dans le même temps et vous n'allez plus
touché c'est quotidienne c'est le même
sujet qui est posé c'est d'ailleurs dans
le cadre de la conférence de financement
questions seront posées
c'est la même sujet qui sera mais l'art
est indépendant mais mathématiquement
mais mathématiques
nous sommes sur les mêmes chiffres mais
vous avez des mécanismes de transition
qui vont qui vont qui vont nécessiter
que dans un cas ça se puisse être
d'ailleurs ça a été dit par un certain
nombre de syndicats les un certain
nombre de réserves qui permettent de
gérer les transitions
c'est valable aussi pardonnez moi
pardonnez moi je crois en vous beaucoup
d'autres choses dans les stic et moi
comment la question des réserves
elle est aussi la question de la réserve
pour gérer les transitions bien mais
pour l'instant les réserves ces 25 c à
seulement 1 milliard qui pourront
peut-être s'est alors mobilisée dans la
réunion qui va avoir lieu bientôt il a
joué dans de chaudes là on atteint 4
milliards c'est pas mes chiffres
ces quatre milliards par an non à 2025 à
2040 vous faites là 10 mais celles ci
sont guignard donc en réalité on n'en
aurait pas d'alliance et relâché parce
qu'enfin me confirmez vous me confirmer
que les gens qui ont cotisé bien
évidemment au droit de recevoir les
retraites qui correspondent à leurs
cotisations mais que très prochainement
il n'y aura plus les cotisations
nécessaire pour les pays donc c'est
l'état qui va payer je vous parle
pardon monsieur cochrane est excusez moi
j'essaie de voir s'y attendait c'est
valable dans un mécanisme qui est en
transition il ya aussi les cotisations
de ceux qui bénéficiaient de tel ou tel
régime spécial donc il faudra payer les
pensions de retraite tandis que le
système sera d'une autre nature
et c'est bien là que je vous dis que la
question des réserves et d'ailleurs les
je répète les syndicats pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux l'ont dit c'est dans
le mécanisme de transition les réserves
doivent pas servir à financer le système
final les réserves et doivent faire
permettre de financer les transitions et
ça fait partie des choses pareilles mais
c'était par ailleurs je vous dis que je
ne suis pas d'accord sur les chiffres
mais je ne prétends pas être un expert
total de cette question des retraites il
faut aussi enseigné vous parce que c'est
chez c'est pas le cas ça peut pas être 4
milliards par an et ce à raison parce
que tout le monde social à nantes tout
le monde
non tout le monde ne rentre pas à la
retraite au même moment donc je vous
parle donc il ya un mécanisme de
productivité observé il ya ainsi de
m'équiper comme alors vous avez cotisé
justement fini servirait posé une
question sur le financement des
retraites ça fait deux ans et demi que
cette réforme des retraites et sur la
tâche deux ans pendant lesquels
jean-paul delevoye a discuté avec les
syndicats on a vu le résultat et puis
deux
six mois on sait à peu près vers où
l'ombre mais nous n'avons aucun chiffre
pour nous éclairer sur les enjeux
budgétaires
c'est quand même absolument incroyable
et d'ailleurs lors du débat au sénat la
semaine dernière on a interrogé des
secrétaires d'état qui a été incapable
de répondre
et c'est vrai que nos collègues et là
m'ont dit que ces terres naufrage on en
est au point où le gouvernement a déposé
un texte l'assemblée nationale va devoir
l'examiner dans les semaines qui
viennent le sénat le fera après et nous
allons le faire en première lecture est
d'ailleurs le premier ministre l'a
confirmé dans la lettre qu'il a adressée
aux syndicats nous allons le faire
examen du texte en première lecture en
ne sachant rien des enjeux budgétaires
et de la manière dont nous allons les
règles voilà leurs pions je vous ai
entendu monsieur le ministre dira que ce
te pas tellement un problème qu'on avait
déjà fait ça dans le passé alors je vais
me rappelait que c'est d'ailleurs dans
ce pays et qui s'abat sur cette
institution et qui impose qu
effectivement pour tout texte de loi
renée d'étude d'impact et qu'est ce
qu'il ya de plus important que le
financement de cette énorme aux réformes
si ce n'est son financement et donc vous
êtes en train de dire au parlement
vous allez débattre d'un texte en
première lecture sans rien savoir des
conditions de financement vous pensez
pas qu'il ya un sacré mépris pour le
parlement moi je crois pas du tout que
de mépris pour le parlement
le point de désaccord que j'avais vous
je suis absolument d'accord avec l'idée
qu'il faudra crédiblement devant le
sénat et devant l'assemblée nationale
qu'on dise comment tout ça est financé à
jeudi on peut pas non mais ce sera
l'objet sera l'objet attendait ça sera
l'objet je fais confiance et au sénat et
à l'assemblée nationale en particulier
aux oppositions pour lever ce sujet
d'ailleurs c'est ce que vous faites ce
soit tous les deux sous des formes de
nature différente
il ya des éléments qui sont ce qui a été
dit par le gouvernement sur la tendance
générale c'est-à-dire l'idée que les
grandes tendances générales de
financement reste est celle qui était
aujourd'hui qui préside aujourd'hui au
système tel que nous le connaissons deux
enfants des crayons attendait monsieur
monsieur d'année c'est de vous répond
2 que l'hymne l'objectif c'était on
reste à 14% du produit intérieur billets
bri brut sachant que le produit
intérieur but lui-même évolué puisque
normalement nous avons de la croissance
et donc cette richesse-là augmente et
que c'était l'objectif final de l'
équilibre et que les grandes tendances
données après il me semble que les
questions que vous posez qui sont pas
illégitimes notamment les questions
qu'on pose et monsieur coquerel sur les
transitions elles sont l'objet de la
conférence
nous nous avions posé une mesure qui
était une mesure hp bourse
a suffisamment reproché on peut pas nous
avoir reproché le dire nous avait déjà
dit ça non parce que c'est le parlement
il se sent méprisée malin je signe je
finis ce rapport jeudi à philippe
dallier et monsieur coquerel aussi
d'ailleurs eric coquerel aussi que le
parlement il pourra délibérer
valablement puisque d'abord pour ce qui
est du sénat en deuxième lecture non ça
vous pose pas un problème tous pour ce
qui est du sénat monsieur d'allier
probablement la lecture est enfin avril
le sénat pourra saisir avec des éléments
budgétaires quant à l'assemblée
nationale y aura une deuxième lecture
probablement je vois pas qu'est une
commission mixte paritaire conclusive
sur le sujet et je ne doute pas que même
dans la première lecture
il ya un certain nombre d'éléments qui
puisse être n'importe qui peut
d'ailleurs aussi des contributions mais
un élément qu'il soit porté sur l'
équilibre budgétaire du système je lui
dise quels sous les syndicats dans une
question des progrès de l'assemblée qui
jourde je pense qu'à l'assemblée
nationale la commission travaille déjà
la commission au sénat pas encore mais
la lie très prochainement au sénat on va
faire les mêmes choses qu'elle est
l'équation budgétaire à résoudre il est
quand même incroyable que le
gouvernement ne soit pas capable de nous
dire le corps nous a dit qu'en 2025 qui
manque plusieurs habitations des
retraites entre 7 et 17 milliards votre
réforme elle va coûter vous le dites
vous même
il va falloir faire converger les
systèmes tout cela tout cela demande
effectivement des moyens supplémentaires
combien avant même qu'on réponde à la
question comment combien ministre ne
répond même pas cette question et
d'alien nous avions c'est pour ça que je
revenais sur mon affaire d'âge pivoda
les équilibres nous avions proposé une
mesure qui étaient autour de l'âge
déquilibre ça ne suffisait pas brillé
mais peut-être qu'après on peut en
débattre au parlement être peut-être pas
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec nous mais
c'était la mesure que nous avions
proposé 12 milliards par an ça ne suffit
pas mme soleil c'était la mesure après
acceptons qu'on puisse en sais pas ça
c'est normal dans le débat démocratique
les partenaires sociaux pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux ont dit 'nous on
pense qu'à d'autres solutions mais nous
nous avions et d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'exprime le premier ministe dans sa
dans sa lettre de cadrage pour nous
c'est au tour de ceux de ce dispositif
là que les choses pouvaient fonctionner
à vrai dire qu'est ce que vous proposez
vous pour ce qui est des républicains
sans vouloir travers votre pensée
j'essaie toujours de séquelles proposé
dès lors que l'âge de soixante 60 ans et
on l'a su et de et on l'attendait me
souviens d'un seul d'allier
suivons mais je vous le fais pas le
reproche s'éloigner en termes
d'équilibré savoure mettiez pas en
causes de fait que ça équilibre et 6 ans
et vit coquerel lui voudrais vous poser
qui sont aussi sur le fait que cette
réforme ouvre une retraite par
capitalisation
oui alors c'est intéressant ce coup mais
on m'a répondu m'a dit je vais peut-être
pas d'accord avec vos chiffres enfin
vous admettez l'e-mail bravo chiffres
oui mais d'accord mais vous admettez que
le chiffre est important qu'il ya dans
ce que j'ai à vous dire
donc ce que je constate c'est que on est
sur un système où au-delà 10000 euros
pour l'instant dans le système actuel il
n'y avait pas de trou le trou de me2
qu'on va provoquer puisqu'on va passer
de 27 % de cotisation à 2 8% pour un
gouvernement encore une fois qui nous
dit que tout est question d'équilibré
des recettes donc le maire plusieurs
c'est qu'il ne fait pas moi j'ai une
deuxième question liée à ça donc vous
l'avez dit les les cadres qui jusqu'à
maintenant payer 27 % cotisation est
cadre dans l'avenir pas ceux qui ont
cotisé dons car les instances vont cette
fois-ci cotiser à hauteur de 10% et ils
ne toucheront pas le complément la
retraite qui est qui qui veulent adhérer
à l'organisation
d'accord nous en déclin amis vous
reconnaîtra bien alors ma question aller
simple c'est que quand vont-ils faire
qu'est ce qui va se passer n'importe
quelle personne qui travaille dans une
société indépendante aux autres c'est
très bien que dans ces cas là il ya des
fonds de capitalisation qui arrivent et
qui vous disent ben vous voyez bien la
retraite par répartition ne vous
rapporte plus haut tant qu'elles
rapportaient à vos prédécesseurs donc
nous on vous propose ses solutions aux
risques c'est la question qui est posée
est fait vous vous dites nom vous dit
non il n'ya pas s'est passé ce n'est pas
l'objectif
que vient faire dans ces cas là dans
votre projet de loi l'article 64 du
chapitre 2 qui explique qu'il est
question de généraliser justement les
épargne retraite qui fait référence à la
loi pacte voter c'est à dire qui a
permis de défiscaliser à la fois les
cotisations retraite par capitalisation
est ce qu'ils toucheront tient au
grattage de tirage les gens qui iront
vers la retraite par capitalisation en
bénéficieront deux fois donc moi ma
question est simple on nous dit on veut
en finir avec les régimes spéciaux mais
ce que je remarque s'il y en a qui on
veut avec lequel on ne veut pas en finir
qu'est la retraite par capitalisation au
contraire vous voulez la généraliser les
messieurs
comme vous venez de dire la gentille de
reformuler la question de ce cocktail
mais je peux me permettre de dire
qu'elles n'étaient plus vaste que ça le
système départ en retraite il existe en
france
oui mais non mais n'est pas générale la
question la question du système par
répartition c'est bien ça qui nous
préoccupe le système paraty partition je
le dis pas pour vous mais je ne dis pas
qu'on se mette bien d'accord l'idée
c'est que les actifs payent pour les
retraités et que c'est collectivement et
dans un système universel vous
reconnaîtrez cas plus de solidarité que
dans le système il ya 42 régime qui en
silo ne se parlent pas les uns avec les
autres donc que ya des retraites par
capitalisation elle existe elle existe
il n'ya pas une question de
généralisation en tant que tel et que
nous voulions mais là c'est à dire dans
votre langue et de généraliser ce n'est
pas vous parler de le favoriser
mais ses marques et que je ne cite que
vous dit ce n'est pas nous qui avons
ouvert la voie à la renommée de la non
là on ne suivait pas de nouveauté de ce
côté là non il vous l'a créé pas vous la
générale 1 c'est donc sur ce qu'il est
en même temps le vide
vous dites à ces rumeurs de coquerelles
il devrait officier qu'est ce que ces
normes le système d'ailleurs je disais
ça dans un un journal du matin qui n'est
pas forcément un journal qui ont soin de
votre obédience qui disait plutôt que
c'est un système qui est massivement
redistributif quoi la capitalisation en
avant le système vous est taquin le
système que nous proposons est un
système qui est massivement
redistributif pourquoi parce qu'un
certain nombre de gens qui avaient des
retraites très faible vont avoir une
retraite qui sont des centres plus tard
non mais c'est pas plus tard place qu'il
était sur l on peut ne pas être d'accord
on peut ne pas être d'accord sur ce que
vous dites sur les padres à va peut être
pas mais attendez vous pouvez me
garantit que les preuves d'abord un
tiers 64 65 soit six ans à part que des
droits mais peut-être que ces quelques
centaines d'heures à peu à partir de
2020 tel que c'est proposer les gens qui
sont obligés et s'ils existent ces gens
là et vous les croisez autant que moi
qui sont obligés d'aller jusqu'à 67 ans
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le nombre de
trimestre petit à petit on réduit bhl
ont réduit le nombre de mois pour qui y
convergent vers l'âge déquilibre mais si
c'est exactement comme ça explicitement
que pour un mini cela demande encore
pourquoi parce que ça permet à tout le
monde d'être dans le même système mais
si monsieur coquerelles et donc est par
ailleurs donc tout ça est un mécanisme
qui est profondément redistributive et
donc les pannes retraite qui existent
déjà
qu'elle soit puisse y être favorisés
c'est pas une nouveauté sous le soleil
en tout si c'est une nouveauté quand
vous la généraliser que pour les revenus
vous vous allez défavorisés les hauts
revenus puisqu'il d'un côté cotiseront -
ils recevront donc vous allez vous avez
l'avantagé alors votre réponse non en
fait il ferme et el milia pas très clair
voudrait aller lui aussi j'ai toujours
sur les retraites à propos justement des
comptes publics parce que tout ça c'est
vraiment les grands équilibres qui sont
hors jeu vidéo écoutez monsieur ministre
mais c'est clairement assumé par le
gouvernement l'objectif de retour à
l'équilibré des comptes publics en 2022
a été abandonné l'année dernière après
la crise des jaunes voilà verrou est ce
que nous allons dieu seul le sait
aujourd'hui en tous les cas on sera pas
l'équilibré et la dette continuent
grossir sur l'art sur la réforme des
retraites vous nous dit on va vers un
système il faut aller vers un système
équilibré là dessus je ne peux que vous
suivre ceci étant dit vous aviez
également dit enfin vous gouvernement
avait également dit que on ne toucherait
pas aux réserves accumulées aujourd'hui
dans les régimes complémentaires
notamment l'agirc-arrco où on a entre
100 et 120 milliards de réserves
il me semble qu'on voit se dessiner une
formule si effectivement touche pas tout
à fait à l'aise équilibre sur n'augmente
pas les cotisations
j'ai bien le sentiment qu'on va vers une
formule on utiliserait le fonds de
réserve des retraites que jospin avait
créé justement pour passer les années
difficiles et pas pour une transition du
pour vers une nouvelle réforme et j'ai
le sentiment que se dessine une solution
où on irait effectivement puiser dans
les réserves de ces régimes
complémentaires
alors oui ou non monsieur le ministre
parce que je pense que les français pour
l'instant
et notamment tous les salariés qui
risquent bien d'être les dindons de la
farce de cette réforme
pour l'instant personne ne s'inquiète
vraiment alors oui ou non les réserves
de l'agirc-arrco seront elles préserver
intégralement mais à quoi à quoi servent
elles c'est assez réservé là comme
d'autres d'ailleurs
c'est effectivement il s'est assez lourd
ou salariés c'est à dire à ceux qui
avaient cotisé pour aimer comme vous
avez effectivement créé ce régime
universel où tout va être mélangés les
douaniers je me demande effectuée ce
sinistre est pour certains gros célèbre
la noblesse à servir à brême shell et
roudet alors les messieurs 13
coquerel ce n'est pas une réforme
distributive et dire ça va coûter de
l'argent oui ça va on sait que tu nommes
été témoin
car là pour aller financer le reste la
session l'insoumise le premier ministre
très clairement et dès le début quand il
a été interrogé sur cette question de il
ya pas que le régime agirc arrco il ya
d'autres caisses avec des reprises
importe pas c'est sûr mais on peut
généraliser la question c'est ce que je
vais vous dire le prémunit stadiers très
clairement que ça n'était pas pour objet
ces réserves n'avait pas pour objet de
financer le système cible elle pouvait
avoir pour objet il ya un certain nombre
de partenaires sociaux il semble qu'il
ya des syndicats qui le disent que les
mécanismes de transition qui servirait
ceux qui ont cotisé pouvaient être
mobilisées en termes de réserves
il n'ya pas monsieur hirsch a causé leur
feront découvrir peu à peu commencé
fillon c'est cette réserve est monsieur
le ministre je vous dis que ça va avoir
beaucoup nous aurons le débat mais
j'entends des organisations syndicales
vont reconnaître avec moi qu'ils disent
dans le cocktail de mesures qui peuvent
être proposées à déterminer deux
ministres sont passés à autre chose
il me semble que l'un de ces syndicats
ou même l'autre d'ailleurs oui enfin une
mission qui sont assez représentatifs
comme dossongui je sais pas parce qu'ils
sont ensemble ils évoquent sans réseau
minoritaire à l'assemblée s'il vous
plaît terminé peu de place sur la
recherche jeudi la question des réserves
ça a été dit par un certain nombre
d'organisations syndicales ça peut être
mobilisé non pas pour financer
généralement le système est redistribué
surdotées à l'intérieur du système pour
regarder comme on gère au mieux les les
mécanismes de transition
c'est pas très lourd à ce qu'on vient de
dire mais laissons pas vraiment la scène
arrive ils sont allés servi par vous me
qualifiez conditions ce sont d'abord les
régimes spéciaux que vous voulez
supprimer ce sont des régimes sont ceux
qui ont les retraites minimum etc
donc on a quand même la crainte que ces
réserves la qui sont les plus importants
et vous devrez faire confirmer ici mais
je n'irai pas voir cette rafle a promené
sa décla clairement que ce n'était pas
bien alors vous vouliez parler eric
coquerel des violences policières
également qui sont au coeur de
l'actualité également puisque christophe
castaner aujourd'hui à d'ailleurs
rappelé à l'ordre en disant que la
mesure était la règle d'or des forces de
l'ordre voulu poser une question oui
j'avais une question ça fait à peu près
un an qu'il ya des manifestations dans
ce pays et que on vend moins en convenir
il ya un nombre impressionnant blessés
graves
de gens mis en garde à vue de gens
arrêtés plus qu'aucun autre mouvement
bon là il ya d'immatriculation
syndicales notamment jeudi samedi où on
a tous vu des images de tir à l bd
quasiment à bout portant 2 me de
syndicalistes eu notamment je pense une
selle calice de l'unsa qui s'appelle
irène taper à plusieurs reprises qu'elle
ramasse et son téléphone images de
croche pied enfin plein de choses j'ai
compris commises l'intérieur demandé aux
forces de police d'être exemplaire mais
j'aimerais connaître votre avis votre
position notamment sur la manière dont
ce fait le maintien de l'ordre à paris
parce que je mets en question le préfet
l'allemand dans cette question est est
ce que vous pourriez m'éclairer sur les
la phrase de dupré ministre swiss samedi
dimanche soir la télé qui a expliqué que
en gros lüthi le revendique l
utilisation de la force et qui laissait
penser que tel que les images qu'on
avait vu était finalement légitime
est ce que j'aimerais connaître votre
position relation la premier ministre
je rappelle les débats philosophiques
ont déjà eu lieu sur le sujet que les
forces de police détiennent le monopole
de la violence dite légitime c'est le
corollaire de ça c'est à dire la
nécessité de maintenir l'ordre et
parfois d'utiliser la force qui a dit le
ministre pour maintenir l'ordre le
corollaire de ça c'est l'exemplarité
c'est ce qu'a rappelé aujourd'hui le
ministre de l'intérieur c'est la
nécessité d'être sans faille et donc à
chaque fois qu'il ya une faille à chaque
fois que ça n'est pas exemplaire à
chaque fois qu'il ya quelque chose qui
n'est pas conforme à l'éthique ou à la
pratique il faut d'abord ya des enquêtes
qui sont en cours dans un certain nombre
de ces cas qu'en tout cas il ya des
plaintes qui sont qui sont formulées et
de faire en sorte d'être extrêmement
vigilant à la fois pour les citoyens
mais c'est aussi une manière pour les
forces de l'ordre qui dans leur immense
majorité font leur travail dans des
conditions parce que vous avez dit
depuis un an la d on a des
manifestations depuis un an
reconnaissons vous et moi qu'on
assistait aussi à des scènes à paris en
particulier
je pense à ce qui s'est passé à l'arc de
triomphe je pense qu'à un certain nombre
d'intrusions dans des bâtiments publics
qui étaient des saints des scènes qui
n'avait jamais été vu dans la capitale
qui avait commencé à être vue pour être
très honnête du temps la loi et le
coditel comrie où il y avait eu la
première formulation des violences
possibles explique un pur
votre regard il y avait eu des violences
de manifestants voudrait police et les
forces de police sont des fonctionnaires
qui ont la possibilité d'utiliser la
violence à peu les mêmes joueurs donc je
voudrais avoir votre position sur les
images qu'on avait la manière donc très
clairement non pas la manière dont parce
que c'est moi les policiers ont nui à
l'image des toiles et la manière dont
ces progrès projet safari 7 qui dont il
était question c'est le crochet pas si
c'était à paris d'ailleurs le croche
pied qui a été fait à une manifestants
dont j'ai traversé la cité à toulouse
mais sans que c'était pas pareil pour ça
que vous regardez les choses acceptable
il croyait unissent lavage de cerveau
kalliste taper parce qu'elle n'est pas
commentée des images on les regarde
l'ensemble je n'ai à chaque fois qu elle
s'achève irène lé syndicat salue
monsieur coquerel à chaque fois qu'il y
aura des choses qui ne sont pas
conformes à la règle à l'éthique vous me
trouverez sur le chemin pour vient pas
conforme à la règle article laissez moi
finir jeudi en même temps que vous êtes
face à des phénomènes violents qui sont
résignés domaine violon je parle de
syndicalistes extrêmement pacifique
c'est très compliqué mais ce congrès
vous savez comme moi de maintenir
l'ordre
quand vous avez des éléments
perturbateurs et violent et d'ailleurs
les syndicalistes faut leur rendre
hommage dans les manifestations
syndicales ont essayé pour leur part de
faire en sorte que les syndicats les
manifestations syndicales ne soit pas
polluée par des gens qui vont sous le
des formes diverses de radicalité décidé
d'avoir maille à partir gérer forces de
police ce n'est pas facile pour les
policiers je peux pas laisser aussi
comprenez que pour les manifestants
pacifiques non mis en garde à vue
pendant 48 heures comme ce week-end
j'en connais une personne soit arrêtée
juste place aura qu ils s'épanouissent
et très sereine je ne commente que
l'effet que je connais je ne commande
pas pourquoi il maintenir si un peu
livia sont impatientes jean philippe
dallier voulait poser une question
dernière l'action sur les personnages
sont pas d'accord sur rien nada de l'été
des particuliers est ce un autre sujet
important pour les français le logement
les résultats de notre politique depuis
deux ans le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est qu'ils ne sont pas bons et je vais
pas rentrer sur les chiffres de la
construction où c'est le problème que
rencontrent les bailleurs sociaux gens
revenir sur la réforme des apl vous avez
fait le choix alors d'enlever les 5
euros on s'en souvient il ya deux ans
mais c'est pas de cela dont je parle
vous avez fait le choix d'une réforme
avec la prise en compte des revenus
contemporain des allocataires qui est
une réforme qui changent assez
radicalement la donne et dont le
gouvernement d'ailleurs à temps un
milliard deux d'économies par an cette
réforme
elle a été votée à
l'automne 2018 techniquement on avait
dit que ça serait très compliqué ça n'a
pas pu être mis en place l'année
dernière on en a reparlé à l'automne
lors de la loi de finances ça devait
être mis en place au 1er janvier et là
le gouvernement d écouter non on met ça
en place au 1er avril votre question sur
l'élection municipale monsieur le
ministre qui vous empêche de mettre en
oeuvre cette réforme
ou alors est-ce que l'impréparation mais
vous me répondrez est ce que la
préparation d'une réforme aussi
importante est encore l'explication
réponse
j'ai d'ailleurs pour nous faire beaucoup
de reproches c'est le débat démocratique
il ya des tas de réformes je me souviens
ce que vous avez dit en particulier dans
vos rangs sur la question de la réforme
du prélèvement à la source on nous a
promis l'apocalypse j'aurais aimé
qu'après nous avoir promis la coupe
focalisons nous disent aussi que ça
avait bien fonctionné réponse et en
province non alors quand ça marche bien
on verra sur la durée
moi je pense que les français ils ont
été au rendez vous et ils ont vu que ça
avait bien fonctionné sur la question
qui vous pose que vous n'êtes que vous
posez effectivement il ya un délai mais
c'est pas le gouvernement camerounais se
délasser la caf
c'est regrettable mais le la caf nous à
10 pour que l'on fasse les choses dans
les meilleures conditions possibles et
on a besoin de trois mois de plus ça ne
change on peut nous reprocher aussi
parce que vous faites un deuxième
reproche et pour des motifs électoraux
reconnaissons sur wii alors aussi nous
est tous vraiment dans cette obsession
électorale nous ne serions pas dans le
débat des retraites avant les élections
municipales et l'an dernier nous avons
porté un certain nombre de réformes par
exemple la réforme de la fonction
publique que nous avons porté avant les
élections européennes
on peut nous faire tous les griefs saut
de regarder avec en permanence en
boussole les les élections municipales
ici ou d'autres natures qui pourrait
avoir un impact
il ya manifestement quelque chose qui
n'est pas encore prêt et comme c'est une
réforme très profonde comme vous l'avez
dit qu'ils étaient partagés compris je
crois dans vos rangs par un certain
nombre de gens l'idée de grandes
contemporain c'est à dire à l'instant t
en temps réel les jo ça mais là je le
promets je vous ai pas février c'était
du vôtre crois que nous étions plutôt
vous avez sur le sujet en même temps
c'est très bien un sujet de mise en
oeuvre et pour que la marge mais vous
mais ça se mette en oeuvre dans les
meilleures conditions et aux trois mois
débuteront prendre à leur manière scier
les parlementaires qui sont revenus sur
le plateau face avoue eric coquerel
philippe dallier merci d'être venu sur
ce plateau parce que maintenant il est
l'heure d'accueillir yves thréard qui a
bien écouté ce que vous avez
il ya d'autres questions à vous poser
certainement
bonjour il est très bonnes années 2020
évidemment merci francis bonne année
bonne année monsieur bédié avons
également je suis le ministre tous ça
serait à refaire vous feriez pas pareil
la réforme des retraites
bon je crois pas je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse y aller vous aimez bien dire
'attendez jeudi deux ans de négociations
cacophonie on savait plus très bien à
quoi ressemblait la retraite l'âge pivot
qui débarque qui n'était pas prévu dans
le programme du président de la
république on se dit quand même que si
vous faites un retour d'expérience comme
on lit dans les entreprises vous ferez
l'expérience on le fera quand on aura
entre abou l'expérience on sait pas qui
n'ont pas une x par exemple parce qu'il
ya des étapes on en a parlé
parlementaire il ya des sujets qui sont
sur la table
ceux du financement il ya des débats il
ya des mécanismes de transition donc on
va se donner un peu de temps pour les
pour le retour d'expérience qu'est ce
qui a cloché en même temps il je pense
que la difficulté dans laquelle nous
sommes tous sur cette question de la
réforme des retraites c'est un de
pouvoir décrire le système tel qu'il est
beaucoup de français ont découvert le
système tel qu'il était qu'au fond on
avait dit âge légal à 62 ans et que
beaucoup de gens travailler jusqu'à 67
ans qu'il y avait des retraites
complémentaires qu'il y avait des
systèmes des régimes spéciaux que les
gens ont découvert parce que des régimes
qu'on ne connaissait pas la sienne
j'essaie de répondre à cette question
qu'est-ce qui a caché la difficulté ses
réponses mais vous pouvez mais c'est
juste pardonnez moi sans être taquin
finama phrase donc la difficulté c'est à
décrire un mécanisme qui est déjà
extrêmement complexe dont il faut
expliquer comment on fait le mécanisme
de transition vers un mécanisme finale
et c'est vrai que cette pédagogie là
elle est compliquée et c'est mais je ne
regrette pas qu'on se soit lancé dans la
réforme
je pense que c'est une réforme qui est
profondément juste c'est comme tout
système clair et plus vite non en tout
on peut toujours dire au revoir monsieur
cette histoire l'adage pivot sincèrement
c'était pas prévu dans le programme
emmanuel macron à ce qui était prévu
c'est que ce soit à l'équilibré oui
certes mais pas avec un des chapiteaux
qui s'est appelée équilibre pivot
maintenant on revient à un équilibre
d'ailleurs c'était la volonté de douar
philips d'introduire cette notion
l'armée la volée par l'élite
vous invite à relire ce qu'a dit edouard
philippe le 11 décembre il a dit je
considère que l'âge pivot est une façon
de d'atteindre l'équilibré et de
l'équipe dont on a parlé de
parlementaires attendait et il a dit
dans la même phrase il ya peut-être
d'autres solutions à laquelle les
partenaires sociaux voudront se rallier
donc je mets ça sur la table donc ce
n'était pas quelque chose qui est sur
lequel c'était à reconnecter le 1er mai
c'était son idée quand même mais on a
droit d'avoir des idées quand même du
style it est d'accord enfin pas penser
que sur une réforme de cette ampleur là
vous êtes grands pas quelque chose qui
se valent de l'or d'un alignement à
l'exil est grand pour dire que c'est un
show fait vraiment beaucoup entre le
cabinet du premier ministre et des
services du président de la république
je ne peux je n'ai pas assisté à ça et
j'insiste un certain nombre de réunions
et je n'ai pas assisté à ce que vous
décrivez la corde
vous êtes ministre des relations avec le
parlement vous avez trouvé le premier
ministre avec gagner en volume là avec
cette ce à moi je combats parce que
c'est un combat comme pardonnez moi je
n'avais pas de doute sur le volume du
premier ministre a ouï dire les choses
comme elles sont parce que je il est
conforté aujourd'hui oui en tout cas la
position qui est la sienne est plutôt
conforté mais je pense pas qu'ils
aillent nous un savoir s'il était
confortée ne pas conforter je pense que
le polémiste est à l'oeuvre que ce n'est
pas la première réforme y compris la
première réforme difficile que nous
essayons c'est la plus difficile les
autres sont passés comme une lettre à la
poste
non c'est pas parce qu'elles sont passés
plus facilement qu'elle n'était pas
difficile
la réforme du droit du travail la
réforme delà du statut de la sncf
la maison sncf la réforme de l'assurance
chômage la réforme de la formation
professionnelle la réforme de
l'éducation nationale je peux vous
continuer la liste je n'étais pas d'airé
sauf que cette fois c'est sur fond
d'élections municipales alors chef fathi
non c'est pas ça c'est que vous n'avez
pas peur que vous soyez sanctionné à
l'occasion de ces élections municipales
qui auront lieu dont on a deux profs je
n'ai pas peur à cause de cette rétro
bien je n'avais pas peur du jugement des
français
quand je pense qu'une réforme est juste
et cette réforme au bout les français
verront qu'elle est juste deux forces
je n'ai pas peur du vide alors c'est
quand vous faites de la politique et que
vous avez peur dès que vous proposer une
réforme il vaut mieux je pense faire
autre chose et pendant des années parce
que on a eu peur alors qu'on a eu peur
de son côté redoutez-vous mais non je ne
redoute pas parce que d'ailleurs vous ne
prendrez pas en défaut de ne pas avoir
dit que pour moi les élections
municipales étaient des élections
locales alors que la question est que la
question quel est pose justement voyage
et au fait vous verrez à laquelle
répondront c est ce que celui ci ou
celui là est le meilleur mais parce que
c'est trop facile pour voir les
localement vous êtes des rixes pas très
loin de pau pas très bon vieux port de
pêche mais c'est plutôt une citation
d'un station balnéaire ya un petit port
de pêche aussi à biarritz et se connaît
se dit ah
deux candidats assez alors il ya un duel
assez curieux le maire actuel qui est un
le maire sortant est soutenu par jean
baptiste lemoyne qui est secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes et aux
affaires étrangères temps modernes le
maire sortant était modem il apparaît a
pas de partie et puis en face il ya un
candidat qui a surgi le ministre de
l'agriculture didier guillaume en 07 à
liszt et qui va donc se retrouver en
concurrence avec un autre ministre dans
cette bonne ville de biarritz ça vous ça
vous chagrine ça c'est jamais très
agréable d'avoir d'abord pourquoi il
fait ça guillaume c'est pas bien et lui
demanderais je pense qu'il avait une
envie de l'implantation à biarritz notre
qu'étudier qui connaît bien mais c'est
le même d'ailleurs motifs qui justifient
la candidature sur la liste originale vo
jean-baptiste lemoyne
oui on pourrait assez aisément se passer
de ce genre d'exercice avait essayé vous
de jouer
nous semble que c'est toujours dommage
dans ce cas là mais il y en a des tas
d'autres on peut avoir ce sujet là et on
a essayé de faire converger les
positions ce tournage on craque quand on
n'arrive pas à faire converger les
positions au fond l'idée c'est qu est ce
qu ont ils ont envie l'un et l'autre
pour biarritz il me semble que les tirs
ici pendant la même majorité peut-être
qu'ils auraient pu avoir la même vision
du risque de perdre et l'un et l'autre à
la division il ya eu des exemples
précédents
d'anciens membres du gouvernement
s'étaient madame votera et monsieur du
très bon vin c'est ça a produit
l'élection de madame hazan alors vous
vous êtes me tendre une perche et à part
un dialogue entre monsieur ville a dit
alan mia j'ai voulu un choix qui est
très claire de la république en marche
qui soutient benjamin vevo cédric
villani est un dissident mais de dire
les choses comme étant le modèle va
donner sa position dans les jours
toujours on va vous le seriez le chu
bayrou comme moi avait dit
ça serait peut-être pas mal que ça soit
edouard philippe ou encore philippe a
répondu à cette question et je crois que
françois bayrou avait éventuellement
explorer d'autres pistes mais je croyais
ce butin oui agnès buzyn vous mais moi
ce qui me préoccupe
je sens chez les parisiens une volonté
d'alternance je sens chez les parisiens
le fait où ils ont un peu assez de la
gouvernance et de la manière dont cette
ville est gérée et qu'ils auront envie
d'une alternance et nous modem mais moi
en général je souhaite que nous créons
les conditions de l'alternance et les
conditions de l'alternance là comme à
biarritz et comme ailleurs c'est quand
même plutôt de produire du rassemblement
que de la dissension oui et donc ce
qu'il faut qu'on regarde c'est ce qu'on
va regarder c'est les conditions d'un
rassemblement qui sont un rassemblement
très large parce qu'on voit bien qu'à
paris il ya des gens qui issus de la
droite ont envie de la même alternance
et partage le point de vue qu'on a sur
la ville vous pensez à des gens puis les
bouchots oui par exemple fini goujon qui
dans le 15e je ne me sens pas éloigné je
ne connais pas personnellement mais de
ce qu'il dit et c'est mon département
d'origine c'est là que je suis né mais
je ne sens pas éloignés de ceux codifier
les bouchons non là on dit sur la mon
arrondissement d'origine
je ne suis pas candidat kasia non c'est
pas compliqué je dirais que ce qui est
intéressant c'est de savoir est ce que
est ce qu'on crée les conditions de
l'alternance à paris c'est la seule
sujets de préoccupation qui est le mien
et après les personnes doivent gagner un
peu s'effacer pour faire en sorte que
notre actionnaire nous à jour sais pas
je vous dis pas le contraire
2 la question allez-y est-ce que vous
souhaitez que le président de la
république se représente en 2022
oui enfin il me semble c'est à lui
qu'appartient draps évidemment la
décision là bas de soie d'après vous non
je pense que c'était parce que cette
réforme des retraites a pu être peut
être un obstacle qui non je ne crois pas
du tout je pense que moi je croise aussi
beaucoup de gens reconnaissant que cette
grève elle a beaucoup impacter je pense
surtout à ces gens là en ile-de-france
dans mon territoire dans le loir et cher
on parle assez peu en tout cas sous le
regard ce que vous avez de la difficulté
qu'il autour des retraites on me dit
plus tôt c'est une bonne réforme allez-y
elles sont vous n'avez pas eu peur alors
n'avait pas vous par redouter de faire
renaître la droite et renaître la gauche
n'ont pas fondamentalement parce que
la gauche est dans l'incapacité de dire
en quoi cette réforme alors qu'il ya des
tas de mesures en réponse aux
municipales mais non parce que les
municipales ne sont pas une élection de
nature nationale
vous verrez que les commentaires quand
les commentaires sont une chose la
réalité en est une autre
si je peux pas donner des noms pour pas
faire plaisir ou des plaisir aux uns aux
autres mais vous voyez bien qu'il ya des
gens dont on sait qu'ils sont des bons
mer et les gens ne vont pas regarder
leurs étiquettes et leur soutien ou non
au gouvernement ils voteront pour eux
parce qu'ils pensent que c'est des bons
mer et c'est sur ça que ça va se passer
ou que ça peut être le bon maire on lira
les commentaires d'yves parce que je
peux même l'enquêté car aujourd'hui
c'est l'heure de la fin de votre
audition publique marc fesneau merci
nous dira que vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission sur figaro live ainsi que
sur les comptes twitter de lcp public
sénat audition publique revient
évidemment lundi à 19h merci
[Musique]